all right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
Here's the first one.
Hey David.
Why do you keep saying your history and it
seems like obvious BS.
Please stop saying that.
So, so this is a, this is an ongoing thing.
According to the United States census, as
an immigrant from Argentina who came to the
United States and learned English when I got
here, the us census Bureau says that I am
indeed Hispanic or Latino.
Hispanic or Latino is a person of Cuban, Mexican,
Puerto Rican, central or South American descent
or other Spanish culture or origin regardless
of race.
Okay, so a Hispanic or Latino person can be
of any race of any ancestry, any ethnicity
that speaks Spanish or Portuguese from these
countries that are listed.
That is me.
Okay.
Now there's no question that because my ethnicity
is Ashkenazi Jewish and I moved to the United
States young enough to be speaking English
mostly without an accent, except for some
random words that some in the audience or
acquainted with.
I am not ignorant to the reality that my experience
as an adult in the United States once I learned
English in the United States is effectively
that of a white American with whatever degree
of privilege that affords me.
And whatever your belief is about white privilege,
that's not what the argument is about.
Whatever degree you believe exists.
Um, and it would be a little weird to think
that there is no degree of white privilege.
I understand that I have that it is confirmed
to me by virtue of having come to the United
States early enough to, to speak English without
an accent.
And because of the way I look, I'm not identified
as Hispanic, but as far as the census is concerned,
uh, I am Hispanic and of course I was raised
in Hispanic culture and I still of course
have family in Argentina and spend time there
and identify a with all of the things that
are implicit in that.
So, you know, when I talk about on the show
in the context of it, the immigration debate
or whatever, and I talk about being Hispanic,
it's sort of tongue in cheek in the sense
that, I mean, listen, my, my view is primarily
informed by being, uh, you, you, you know,
and an educated person in the United States
who has empathy and cares about economics
and national security and treating people
with dignity.
And the reality is that according to the census,
being Hispanic is not the primary lens through
which I am seeing these issues, at least not
in a conscious way.
Uh, but, uh, it's not BS.
And, um, the, it's funny, there's people in
the audience who think that the idea of me
being Hispanic is BS and there's a contingent
of hatred.
It's in the audience that regularly attack
me in anti Hispanic ways with the slurs that
you often hear about, uh, central and South
Americans and with go back to, you know, Argentina
type of stuff.
In any case.
Yeah, I am Hispanic according to the census.
Um, my, my culture is a, you know, a mix of
South American, Argentinian and uh, uh, cultural
Judaism and just growing up in the Northeast
and, and you know, interestingly enough, a
lot of my culture is more a metropolitan city
culture than anything else, which is often
much more similar between countries than the
culture often is between rural and urban areas
within the United States.
But that's probably a conversation, uh, for
a different day.